[Aplausos]
el cine es una poderosa máquina
cuando vemos una película y protagonista
está enamorado o enamorada todos
recordamos nuestras frustraciones
nuestros enamoramiento de toda nuestra
vida cuando el protagonista siente miedo
entonces estamos sentimos miedo si
apretamos los brazos fuerte y cerramos
los ojos y esperamos que nada pase
lo cierto es que siempre sabemos que se
trata de una película que es una
película que se va a acabar y que se
trata de un actor o una actriz que está
jugando que está actuando que está
enamorada
o que es un actor que está jugando aquí
está que se interior
los invertimos con un tiempo en la
película y dejamos que nos atraviese
pero al final se acabó y seguimos con
nuestra vida común y corriente
yo soy cineasta hago cine pero hago cine
documental cuando una película
documental acabó aquello que vimos en
pantalla
si te sucede aquello que nos hizo
inclinar aquello que nos hizo emocionar
sigue pasando en la vida real en una
parte de nuestro cerebro que lo usa por
eso este documental es la máquina de
empatía más poderosa que ha creado
hacerlo lleva consigo una
responsabilidad enorme es una
responsabilidad en la que he ido cayendo
en cuenta en los últimos años
en el año 2012 tenía la argentina
estudiaba periodismo estaba buscando un
tema para un tesis de grado y casi por
casualidad encontré las imágenes de un
excavadora que estaba rompiendo sacos de
arroz para mostrarlos con la basura los
autores del vídeo eran unos campesinos
de william hay quienes el gobierno les
habían contado a 70 toneladas de arroz
para mezclar la salud basurero
porque en mi país se estaban comenzando
comida para tirarlo a la basura quién
había dado la hora
me tomo un año organizar toda la
información y empezar a entender que era
lo que estaba pasando con unos ahorros
sin mercamara viaje al huila a cabo para
hablar con las personas que habían
grabado ese vídeo a los mismos que le
habían quitado los perros luego volví a
argentina edite toda esta información le
di forma y lo llamé documental 97
no hay 70 el nombre de la resolución que
le prohibía a esos campesinos sembrar
con sus propias semillas
esto era un pedido específico del
gobierno eeuu al gobierno colombiano
para tratar la firma del tratado de
libre comercio con colombia
lo pedía expresamente y lo pedía
expresamente porque necesitaba
concluyente estado de monsanto de
aterrizar con fuerza en nuestro país
una vez sube el documental
estaba ahí pensando que un canario pasar
con mi documental pero justo un año
después de la firma de tratado de libre
comercio entre colombia y eeuu
los campesinos salieron en la calle en
pocas horas paralizaron todo el país el
gobierno respondió con represión yo que
estaba a cinco mil kilómetros de
distancia quizá solidarizarme con ese
palo de una manera que en ese momento
consideré que iba a ser insignificante
subí el documental a youtube para que
todos lo pudieran ver de manera gratuita
y ahí cambió todo
[Música]
puesto que las instituciones
antiguamente había una tradición en
donde los campesinos guardaba las
mejores semillas de su cosecha para
posteriormente volverlas a sembrar pues
yo quería comprar las semillas que traen
los gringos por el tlc sería certificar
i
el documental son tan viral que era para
mí realmente fue muy difícil manejar la
situación me llamaban todo tipo de
medios para preguntarme quién era yo de
dónde había salido como había hecho lo
que había hecho algunos medios grandes
llamaban a la voz del gobierno y
convertían a la voz oficial en la voz
original y la única voz lo pasábamos en
el horario es cerrar esta voz lo que
decía era que el miedo q mental de la
mentira decía que el documental
perseguía intereses oscuros y que yo
yendo al cuarto de los casos era una
ignorante hombre mentiroso
algunos medios me dio el derecho a
réplica pero casi nunca lo hacían en un
horario estelar a las 4 de la mañana 3
de la mañana entonces por esa razón
decidí tomarme las redes implemente una
estrategia en youtube
empecé a publicar estos vídeos aquí
desde las redes sociales de la película
donde empecé a responder una a una las
oposiciones que iba hacia el gobierno
estos vídeos también se vayan virales la
gente los empezaba a compartir y
entonces los medios tener la necesidad
de volver a contactar
un día de esos
llegó a mis manos el teléfono de uno de
los líderes más representativos del
padre un par que ya parece el momento
completaba 20 días en la calle
cuando hablé con él me dijo que quería
incluir el activo de peticiones
derogación de la resolución 970
mientras tanto la gente tomaba el
documental y lo compartía con el lema
el gobierno entonces apoyó el gobierno
amenazó con llevarme ruiz y sin número
de trataba y todo lo que decía el
documental
yo decidí no hacerlo no pudieron
tratarme de las entrevistas que habían
hecho que le había dicho a los
campesinos en donde me descontaban que
ha perdido todo no podía retratar que
retractarme o decir que la mentira una
investigación que había hecho y que
sabía que era cierto
antes de que re comentar llegará a un
millón de vistas el paro se levantó el
gobierno se comprometió entre otras
cosas aquí está la resolución oeste
ese día aparte de sentir una gran
alegría una gran alegría popular la idea
es que en la lucha colectiva
me hice muchas preguntas
una de las preguntas era por qué el
documental se había vuelto a mirar se
trataba un documental de semillas porque
tanta gente había visto el documental
sobre semillas porque la gente lo había
tomado como bandera para que es para
explicar un poco tratar de entender lo
que pasaba en las calles
y entonces entendí que muchísimos de
nosotros habíamos visto en los rostros
de los campesinos que marchaban a
nuestros tíos a nuestros días a nuestros
abuelos a nuestras abuelas a nuestras
familias campesinas que un día hayan
tenido que venir acá a la ciudad para
buscar suerte
el documental había logrado tender un
puente entre el mundo rural y el mundo
urbano
en las cabeceras dos de las ciudades más
importantes de bogotá tunja medellín
cali habían pancartas que decían yo soy
campesino la gente valiosa aduanas
y se reivindicaba al agro de
descendencia
siento que es porque lo que hizo el
documental con la gente que lo vio fue
poder lograr ponerlos en el lugar de los
campesinos por un momento lo voy a dar
por un momento sentir lo que ellos
estaban sintiendo sufrir lo que estaban
sufriendo
y solidarizarnos e indignarnos con esas
toneladas de arroz
con basura
a mi documental 970 me cambió para
siempre me marcó el destino de lo que yo
quería ser el resto un día me di cuenta
que yo quería hacer un cine documental
que ya se recibe vuelos me di cuenta que
a veces no es no es suficiente con
contar una historia que a veces es
necesario contar a que esta historia
rompa la pantalla y que se pueda alinear
con movimientos que si son capaces de
hacer cambios tangibles en nuestra
realidad
me propuse hacer un cine que a la vez
que hablara de problemáticas sociales y
ambientales también quisiera generar un
cambio de conciencia y que ese cambio de
conciencia se pueda traducir en cambios
de nuestra vida cotidiana
raíces y los llamados y del impacto
chile de triple impact
y en este camino de querer hacer cine
triple impacto he conocido a cineastas
que han llevado este argumento y esta
idea a lugares realmente elevados
está el ejemplo de una persona que me ha
inspirado profundamente que se llama
pamela gates es una documentalista
norteamericano que se perdió con la
política internacional de su país y
decidió ir a guatemala a grabar el
genocidio del pueblo indígena en este
país gracias a su película y gracias a
su trabajo el dictado del río sismo fue
llevado a cárcel y pago por sus crímenes
o también es la historia de los derbis y
nasser court que crearon una tecnología
para que las indígenas del perú pueden
contar la historia de cómo el gobierno
de fujimori las esterilizó forzadamente
y así reavivaron el trabajo dentro del
país
también es la historia de la película vi
nunca una película con un contundente
relato que logró parar el avance de
compañías mineras despreocuparse
nacional en áfrica y así protegió el
hogar
designios de bolillas de la montaña
pienso muy honestamente que vivimos en
un momento del mundo y que no se van a
quedar los cielos y que no se vale
quedar los 107 wall políticamente
correctos cuando hay muchas realidades
que no nos gustan realidades con las que
no estamos de acuerdo el momento que
estamos pasando del mundo nos pide los
activos sin excusas nos pide
tomar un mando y hacerlo desde el lugar
donde estamos desde lo que sabemos hacer
yo me imagino al mundo como una máquina
enorme como un reloj en el que cada uno
de nosotros cumple un rol en determinado
momento esos son los motores a veces
hacemos tuber tuercas que tienen que
apretar a veces tenemos que hacer por
días por otros
a mí
ese es el acto sencillo exacto que
consideraba un acto más simbólico me
marcó el camino que se adaptó me indicó
cuál era mi nuca en este mundo
y eso que cada uno de nosotros atraviesa
constantemente por ese acto en el
momento en que tiene que es el hacer
algo y cambiar el mundo que ese sueño
del que responderá
así que esta es la invitación a
encontrar ese lugar desde jugar podemos
hacer un cambio profundo a veces
simplemente se trata arriesgarlo todo
y dejarlo ir sin temor a perder muchas
veces
[Aplausos]